Nos dicen que: "Dada la altura h y el volumen V
de cierto cilindro, Jill usa la fórmula r = √ V
/ πh para calcular su radio que es igual a 20
metros. Si un segundo cilindro tiene el mismo
volumen que el primero, pero es 100 veces más
alto, ¿cuál es su radio?" Pausa este video y trata
de resolverlo. Muy bien, hagamos esto juntos.
Para empezar, siempre me gusta abordar las cosas
intuitivamente. Digamos que el primer cilindro se
ve así y luego el segundo cilindro es 100 veces
más alto. Sería difícil dibujar un cilindro 100
veces más alto, pero si tiene el mismo volumen
tendrá que ser mucho más delgado, de modo que si
queremos mantener el volumen, mientras hacemos el
cilindro más alto -y no voy a dibujarlo 100 veces
más alto-, vamos a tener que disminuir el radio,
así que esperaríamos que el radio fuera bastante
menor que 20 metros. Esa es la primera intuición;
sólo para asegurarnos de no obtener algún
número más grande que 20 metros. Pero,
¿cómo calculamos cuánto mide? Bueno, ahora podemos
volver a la fórmula, y sabemos que Jill calculó
que el radio es igual a 20 metros, entonces 20 =
√ V / πh, y si esta fórmula no te resulta familiar
sólo recuerda que el volumen de un cilindro es
igual al área de la parte superior o inferior,
πr²h por la altura. Y si tuviéramos que calcular r tendríamos
exactamente esta fórmula que usó Jill, de modo
que esta no es una fórmula nueva, probablemente
ya la has visto. Así que sabemos que 20 metros
es igual a esto, y ahora estamos hablando de una
situación en la que la altura es 100 veces mayor.
Entonces este otro cilindro tendrá un radio =
√ V, que va a ser igual, así que escribimos esa
V, π no cambia siempre va a ser π, y ahora en
lugar de h tenemos que la altura es 100 veces mayor,
así que podríamos escribirlo como 100 h. ¿De
qué otra forma podríamos escribir esto? Bueno,
lo que voy a hacer es tratar de sacar el 100 para
poder tener √ V / πh, entonces podría reescribir
esto como √ 1 / 100 • V/πh, que podría escribir
como la √ 1 / 100, estoy usando propiedades de
radicales, por la √ V / πh. Ahora sabemos cuál
es la √ V / πh, sabemos que eso es igual a 20,
y nuestras unidades son metros. Entonces esto es
igual a 20, y luego ¿cuál es la √ 1 / 100? Bueno,
esto es lo mismo que 1 / √ 100, y por
supuesto lo multiplicamos por 20: √ 100,
la raíz principal de 100 es 10, así que el radio
de nuestro nuevo cilindro, del segundo cilindro,
va a ser igual a 1 / 10 • 20 que es igual a 2 metros.
Y hemos terminado. El segundo cilindro tendrá un
radio de 2 metros que corresponde con nuestra
intuición. Si aumentamos nuestra altura en un
factor de 100, entonces nuestro radio disminuirá
en un factor de 10, la razón es que elevamos al
cuadrado el radio justo aquí, entonces si la
altura aumenta en un factor de 100 y el radio
disminuye en un factor de 10 eso hará que toda
esta expresión siga teniendo el mismo volumen.